དཔེ་སྟོན་སློབ་གྲྭ་
རྒན་བདེ་སྐྱིད་ལགས། རྒན་བྱམས་པ་ལྷ་སྒྲོན་ལགས།
རྒན་སྐལ་བཟང་བདེ་སྐྱིད་ལགས། ཁོང་ཚཽ་ང་ཚཽ་ལ་ཡི་གེ་བསླབ་ཀྱི་རེད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽(ར་)Lalipop སྟེར་༼གི་༽འདུག
རྒན་ལགས་༼གིས་༽རྔན་པ་མང་པོ་སྟེར་༼གི་༽འདུག
Lalipop སྟེར་༼གི་༽འདུག Ice cream སྟེར་༼གི་༽འདུག
ཧ་གོ་མ་སོང་།
ང་སུ་གང་གཅིག་ལ་དགའ་པོ་མེད།
ང་གྲོགས་པོ་གཅིག་པོ་ལ་༼མ་ཤུ་༽དགའ་པོ་མེད། གྲོགས་པོ་ཟླ་མཛེས་རེད་ལབ་སོང་ང་ད
འདི་དུག་སྦྲང་། ཨ་ཅག་ཕལ་བྱིས་མ་གཏོགས་དུག་སྦྲང་འདུག་(ད)། འདི་
དུག་སྦྲང་གིས་སོ་བརྒྱབ་༼གི་༽འདུགད
དུག་སྦྔང་སྡུག་ཅག་ཡོད་རེད།
ང་དུག་སྦྲང་ལ་དགའ་པོ་མེད། དུག་སྦྲང་གིས་སོ་བརྒྱབ་༼གི་༽འདུག
སོ་དངོས་གནས་བརྒྱབ་༼གི་༽འདུག(ད)། ང་ཆེན་པོ་གཅིག་ཞུ་དགོས་བས། ཨ་
ཞུས་ན་ག་རེ་བྱེ་ཀྱི་རེད། ཨ་ནི་ཁོང་ཚོས་ང་ཚོ་ལ་སོ་བརྒྱབ་ཀྱི་ར་
ཞེད་ཀྱི་འདུག
ད་ལྟ་མཆོང་རྒྱག་རྒྱག་གི་འདུག
༼ཏིག་ཙ་༽སྒུགས་ཨ། ངས་དུག་སྦྲང་གཅིག་གསད་དགོས་བས།
དུག་སྦྲང་གིས་སོ་བརྒྱབ་༼གི་༽(ར)། སྙིང་རྗེ་གི་མི་འདུག